à cause du cancer on lui a enlevé une
partie de son poumon gauche fin 2015 je
n'avais aucune espérance
je pensais me proposer des soins
palliatifs
âgé de 71 ans il pensait mourir mais la
médecine lui réservé une belle surprise
bon j'ai le respect de votre canne oui
tout est parfait on va son cancer du
poumon a pour l'instant disparu on parle
toujours d'un pronostic est que moins
que trois mois là on est à trois en
trois ans de plus grâce à ce médicament
arriver sur le marché en 2015
j'ai médicaments dans les eaux depuis
que je le plains j'ai comme cher et puis
cancer ce médicament c'est la fat inhibe
qui cible une mutation génétique qui
active le cancer ces traitements très
innovateur centre en augmenter beaucoup
la survie sont en train de donner
beaucoup une qualité de vie mais il ya
un gros coup à payer d'abord payé par le
fabricant le traitement a ensuite été
défrayés par un programme appelé
patients d'exception ce programme
publique pèse certains médicaments en
pilules qui ne sont pas sur la liste
officielle des médicaments de la régie
de l'assurance maladie depuis 2012 le
nombre de patients qui ont bénéficié de
ce programme est passé de 20 à 31000 et
les coûts ont augmenté de 87 à 272
millions une hausse de 2 113 % et ce
même si chaque année le quart des
demandes formulées sont refusés un
passeport qu'on doit laisser mort et du
monde dans une question d'argent
en plus des comprimés il y a aussi les
médicaments intraveineux qui sont payés
eux par les hôpitaux
ils chargent d'habitude autour de 300
d'alors le par jour c'est à peu près
toujours à ça ça vient a dit non dollars
par mois à peu près toutes les
nouveautés une douzaine d'établissements
lance un cri d'alarmé quant au coût des
médicaments et revenus contre le cancer
par exemple aux six des laurentides on
évalue dans le
rapport financier un dépassement
budgétaire de 6,7 millions pour les
médicaments en oncologie
pourtant plusieurs patients comme
jean-paul chalifoux doivent payer ce
traitement de leur poche
au début on sentait des bosses et tous
les gens de ce monsieur chérif lô est
aujourd'hui en rémission alors qu'en
2017 on le croyait condamné envoyé aux
soins palliatifs il rencontre
l'oncologue jacques jolivet qui pense
avoir une solution que j'ai demandé à
monsieur chalifoux si vous l'amenez son
argent au paradis domaine parce que j'ai
dit regardez on pas si ces traitements
leur falloir payer
c'est à peu près 19 $ le traitement
malgré des moyens limités
jean-paul chalifoux décide de payer près
de 20 mille dollars pour les deux
premiers traitements d'immunothérapie
vous à payer avant le traitement il y en
a peut-être le fabricant paix depuis le
troisième traitement vu son efficacité
les forces d'argent plusieurs patients
attendent que les médicaments soient
payés par le secteur public en ce moment
lors ne des patients chez qui on a des
médicaments très bon mais on peut pas
leur donner
difficile pour les médecins qui veulent
donner toutes les chances à leurs
patients on se sent comme un enfant qui
qui veut rentrer chercher des sucreries
et avec les avancées dans le traitement
du cancer et d'autres maladies
les dilemmes quant au paiement des
traitements ne font que commencer
merci ici david gentil les réseaux
canada bon rien